[Applaus]
[Musik]
durch den krieg in der ukraine haben wir
unseren jede menge nachrichten über alle
arten von sanktionen gegen russische
oligarchen gewöhnt die beschlagnahme von
jagdflugzeugen immobilien und unendlich
vielen anderen reichtum dass sie im
ausland besitzen beziehungsweise besaßen
aber was genau verstehen wir eigentlich
unter einem oligarchen sind sie die
wahren herrscher russlands haben sie
einfluss auf den kreml und wie weit
reicht ihre macht wer sind sie überhaupt
ich bin mir sicher dass viele von euch
wenn sie von russischen oligarchen hören
an mächtigen milliardäre denken und ja
vereinfacht ausgedrückt können wir sagen
dass sie so was sind die gleiche
definition könnte aber zum beispiel auch
auf viele amerikanische milliardäre zu
treffen schnell fällt uns da der namen
donald trump 1 ein multimilliardär
welcher die wichtigste machtposition in
den usa und vielleicht sogar in der welt
inne hatte aber nur für vier jahre jump
ist also eindeutig kein oligarch und es
wäre ein stiller ihn als solchen zu
bezeichnen auch in russland hat wladimir
putin im laufe seiner herrschaft schon
so manch mächtigen militär entmachtet
enteignet und sogar eingesperrt und aus
dem land gejagt das ganze ist also weder
in den usa noch in russland so einfach
und eindeutig wie es auf den ersten
blick erscheint deswegen wollen wir in
diesem video dieses ganze gestrüpp der
mächtigen ordentlich entwirren wir
werden euch den durchblick verschaffen
wie das politische schaffen system
russlands funktioniert wer die wahren
herrscher sind und wie das komplexe
beziehungsgeflecht zwischen dem kreml
und den oligarchen funktioniert also
schnallt euch an es geht sofort los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit laden putin seinen sturm der
zerstörung und vernichtung auf die
ukraine losgelassen hat ist stil von
oligarchen die rede und das ziemlich und
differenziert daher sollten wir als
erstes mal eingreifen und definieren was
in dieser ganzen diskussion eigentlich
mit dem begriff oligarch gemeint ist und
was nicht also russische oligarchen sind
extrem reiche geschäftsleute deren
vermögen und geschäfte im wesentlichen
davon abhängen achtung jetzt kommt es
wie nahe sie dem kreml stehen
[Musik]
sie sind so etwas wie die dritte ja
gerade der politischen macht geworden
ein verlängerter arm des kremls im
wirtschaftlichen bereich denn im
gegensatz zur wirtschaft eines normalen
landes ist die russische ein sehr stark
in sich geschlossenes und
zentralisiertes system in der korrupte
beamte und bürokraten durch sogenannte
re kapitalisten ersetzt worden die ihre
gigantischen reichtümer mit hilfe von
seilschaften zwang und bestechung
angehäuft haben als rentier kapitalisten
werden geschäftsleute bezeichnet die mit
er unlauteren wirtschafts praktiken den
zugang zu jeder art von eigentum für
sich und ihr enges umfeld monopolisieren
und auf diese art beträchtliche gewinne
abschöpfen ohne einen beitrag zur
gesellschaft zu leisten es ist schon ein
besonders makabre treppenwitz der
geschichte dass eben jenes land welches
mit der marxistisch-leninistischen
ideologie der gleichheit aller menschen
die ganze welt beglücken wollte nur von
den krassesten raubte kapitalisten
dieses planeten beherrscht wird und so
mittlerweile die allerschlimmste
ungleichverteilung von reichtum aller
entwickelten länder aufweist man muss es
sich einfach auf der zunge zergehen
lassen rund 500 superreichen russen
kontrollieren mehr vermögen als die
ernsten
99,8 prozent an eine derart krasse
ungleichheit kommt wahrlich kein anderes
land heran diese reisten 500 die weniger
als
0,01 prozent der russischen bevölkerung
ausmachen wir sitzen mit insgesamt 640
milliarden dollar mehr als die ärmsten
115 millionen der erwachsenen
bevölkerung und ich frage mich
angesichts dieser erschreckenden zahlen
wieso man in europa gerade oder jenen
politikern die ampel härtesten vorgeben
die größten kämpft das was soziale
gerechtigkeit zu sein so viele fans des
systems putin findet klar dann einige
putin mit dem argument zu entschuldigen
versuchen die große ungleichverteilung
sei schon unter seinem vorgänger boris
jelzin entstanden ist ja das stimmt zwar
aber putin hat nicht nur nichts gegen
ihr weiteres auf und von getan er hat es
tatkräftig unterstützt auf ganz neue
höhen getrieben und für seine zwecke
maximal ausgenutzt und nein es ist eben
nicht so dass von den vielen milliarden
welche nach russland durch den
rohstoffexport gießen nennenswerte
beträge bei der mehrheit der menschen
ankommen würden und die hälfte der
russischen familien verfügen gerade mal
über ein einkommen mit dem sie ihren
hunger stillen und sich einigermaßen
ordentlich anziehen können zwei drittel
der haushalte können sich noch nicht
einmal eine neue waschmaschine leisten
und während im jahr 2020 das verfügbare
realeinkommen der russen um 3,6 prozent
sank schnell der reichtum der oligarchen
um sagenhafte 45 prozent in die höhe 45
prozent in nur einem jahr dass meine
lieben zuschauer ist das system putin
das sozialste wirtschaftssystem der welt
zumindest wenn man von total
irrelevanten und dysfunktionalen
volkswirtschaften wie nordkorea ab sieht
allerdings ist putins reich auch diesem
so nah wie nie zuvor im heutigen
russland gibt es im grunde weder ein
kapitalistisches noch ein
sozialistisches modell wo dieses land
ist so was wie die liebende verkörperung
eines modernen picken merkantilismus
oder vätern kapitalismus
ein modell in dem die superreichen und
große unternehmen von der politischen
macht alle möglichen privilegien
erhalten solange sie diese macht
unterstützen und ihre richtlinien
befolgen daher ist er diesem land die
beziehungen zwischen privaten reichtum
und staatlicher macht sehr eng sehr eng
eigentlich in höchstem maße inzestuös
die oligarchischen leiten und
kontrollieren strategischen sektoren für
moskaus interessen wie zum beispiel
energie oder verteidigung und aber wie
ist es eigentlich so weit gekommen
die wahrheit ist dass wir uns bereits in
der zweiten generation der russische
oligarch ii befinden die erste
generation ist aus den chaotischen
privatisierungsprozess hervorgegangen
wäre das land in den 1990 er jahren
durchlief als der russische staat wie
der großen straße unternehmen aus dass
frau wird er zu schnäppchenpreisen
verschleuderte wohlgemerkt diese
schnäppchen gab es nur für einen
winzigen kreis auserwählter es war ein
von korruption durchzogener prozess der
auf aktien krediten basiert als system
das die aktien großer staatlicher
rohstoffunternehmen als eine art
sicherheit für kredite an die regierung
nutzte und da die regierung diese
kredite nicht zurückzahlen und zwar auf
verdächtig absichtliche weise
versteigerten die gläubiger diese aktien
um ihre kredite zurückzubekommen und bei
ihnen handelte es sich um zwielichtige
talkurs und der staatlichen und
geheimdienstlichen macht nahestehende
person diese auktion war natürlich
komplett intransparent und manipuliert
denn sie hatten das genaue gegenteil
einer versteigerung zum zweck möglichst
viele potenzielle käufer auszuschließen
so dass der einzige verbleibende käufer
alle reichtümer zum schnäppchenpreis
übernehmen konnte
auf diese weise entstand die erste
generation der oligarchen sie übernahm
die kontrolle über die großen
unternehmen des landes und ersetzten
somit die beamten und bürokraten der
firma sozialistischen planwirtschaft
quasi über nacht gegen russland vom
sozialismus zum klicken merkantilismus
über diese anfängliche protest fand
während der jetzt in ihrer stadt und
wurde dann unter seinem von ihm selbst
auserkorenen nachfolger putin in seiner
noch perverser perfektion getrieben
marcel ziehen und wladimir putin wirken
nach außen die antagonistische
charaktere die trotz ihrer politischen
verbundenheit irgendwie nicht gut
miteinander auskommen natürlich hat
jeder von ihnen seine eigenen einfluss
gruppen aber irgendwann setzen sich
diese zusammen um sich endlose eintrag
das fell des von ihnen erlebten
russischen bären aufzuteilen unbemerkt
nur unter sich unter keinem anderen mit
putin kam so die zweite generation der
oligarchen ins spiel sein auto rasch
bahnte sich ihren weg durch großzügige
regierungs verträge prozessionen und
genehmigungen um die schaltstellen den
nationalen wirtschaft zu übernehmen und
die reichtümer des landes auszubeuten
auf diese weise besetzten sie nach und
nach die höchsten sprossen der
russischen wirtschaftsstruktur es mag
einige überraschen aber der russiche
klicken merkantilismus funktioniert
nicht viel anders als die organisierte
kriminalität in der tat ist der
russische präsident ein spezialist darin
jeden loszuwerden der ihm unangenehm ist
zum beispiel durch sogenannte anti
korruptions kampagne nach dem motto der
dieb schreit haltet den dieb
nehmen wir zum beispiel den fall von
michael rogowski einem ex oligarchen der
jetzigen sachstand und damals zum
reichsten mann russlands aufstieg bis er
2003 wegen korruptionsvorwürfen
verhaftet wurde kolakowski ölkonzern
jukos wurde enteignet und in großen
teilen dem von putins leuten
kontrollierten raßnitz zugeschanzt
26 zu oktober 2003 polizei in russland
öl magnaten fest der reichste mann
russlands öl baron michael b kolakowski
wurde am samstag mit vorgehaltener waffe
von sicherheitskräften der regierung
festgenommen und wegen betrugs und
steuerhinterziehung inhaftiert all diese
anschuldigungen mögen war gewesen sein
aber sie waren sicherlich keine ausnahme
korruption ist ein notwendiger
bestandteil des vorherrschenden
politischen modells in diesem land es
handelt sich also um einen klassischen
fall selektiver justiz kolakowski wurde
exemplarisch vorgeführt da das korrupte
system das ihnen selbst reich gemacht
hatte beenden wollte er trat für eine
wende ein hin zu mehr transparenz und
rechtsstaatlichkeit das konnte in putin
natürlich nicht durchgehen lassen die
operation gegen den reichsten
unternehmer russlands im jahr 2003 war
putin erster warnschuss an die übrigen
oligarchen passt bloß auf wer auf eigene
faust losziehen will wird die
konsequenzen tragen ihr seid dort wo ihr
seid meine politischen macht wenn ihr
also nicht absolut loyal sein und schön
weiter macht wie ich sage dir dafür
teuer bezahlen
[Musik]
in russland sieht sich diese art von auf
dem kopf gestellter
korruptionsbekämpfung durch alle
schichten der gesellschaft des
staatswesens und der wirtschaft nicht
diejenigen die coop sind landen vor
gericht und im gefängnis sondern
umgekehrt jene die sich weigern
besprechungen anzunehmen und ein
korruptionssystem mitzumachen es wird
dann kompromittierendes material aus der
vergangenheit gegen sie angebracht oder
bei bedarf fabriziert deswegen wir
finden wir unter den illegal schon keine
revolutionären und repariere alle thomas
kohler dietmar hopp die mit ihrem
innovation und unternehmergeist mehrwert
schaffen oder den menschheit
voranbringen es kann bei ihnen noch
nicht mal von geschäfts- oder kaufleuten
die rede sein ihn normal miteinander
konkurrieren und risiken eingehen ganz
und gar nicht im russischen modell des
klee und hellberg atheismus
verträglicher gesunden wettbewerb durch
gefälligkeits geschäfte einflussnahme
bestechung und korruption aller art
ersetzt im gegenzug für vermögen
verpflichten sich die oligarchen zu
stabilität loyalität gegenüber der
politischen macht und sie versuchen ihre
unternehmen so gut wie möglich zu führen
nun ja zumindest erzählen sie etwas
bessere ergebnisse als zu sowjetzeiten
wohl aber auch weil sich russland
gegenüber dem ausland geöffnet hat was
alleine schon jede menge energie und
wettbewerbs effekte mit sich bringt
trotzdem darf man sich keinen illusionen
hingeben was die gesamte heutige
russische wirtschaft der reichtum der
oligarchen unter einfluss putins beruhen
nur auf ihrem großen glück dass sie
gerade zu einem zeitpunkt an die macht
kamen kurz bevor die weltmarktpreise für
energie und rohstoffe durch die decke
gingen und sich dann vor allem wegen des
aufstiegs der chinesischen wirtschaft ab
2005 für recht lange zeit auf hohem
niveau hielten die aus dem ausland
fließenden geldströme waren so gewaltig
dass auch die geschicktesten
kleptokraten ist nicht schafften alles
das uns zu klauen so dass ein paar
kleine tropfen auch bis unten zum
russischen volk durch vertreten und für
einen sehr bescheidenen wohlstand sorgt
ohne diese fügung der weltwirtschaft
würde es auch heute in russland nicht
anders aussehen als in den krisenhaften
lose 90er jahren aber jetzt wo wir
wissen was genau ein oligarch ist und
warum so viel über sie gesprochen wird
stellt sich die frage wer genau sind die
wahren besitzer russlands welche
veränderungen laden mir putin
herbeigeführt und die weit erreichte ein
fluss des russischen präsidenten auf die
großen unternehmen des landes genau das
nehmen wir jetzt
das genauer unter die lupe
[Musik]
die aktionäre der russland ag
das russische oligarchen modell hat die
wir euch bereits erklärt haben zwei
grundsätzliche phasen durchlaufen die
von jelzin und die von putin die erste
war durch die enorme politische macht
gekennzeichnet die einige der oligarchen
erlangten in einigen fällen diktierten
sie der regierung sogar die richtung
ihrer politik und wurden mitglieder des
kabinetts oder der regierung in der
zweiten phase änderte sich diese
situation jedoch radikal putin
etablierte mit eiserner faust an eine
ganz andere beziehung die oligarchen
würden sich nicht mehr einmischen oder
der regierung bedingungen stellen dürfen
es wurde ihnen klar gemacht dass die
macht über russland im kreml liegt und
nicht in ihren konzernzentralen
[Musik]
zudem bringt er auf regeln und gesetze
mit denen die großen organischen
strategische branchen wie energie
bergbau der medien dazu gezwungen wurden
teile ihre unternehmen an den staat oder
ein von ihm kontrollierte unternehmen
abzudrücken die idee ein wehr war die
beziehungen zwischen dem kreml und dem
großen russischen unternehmen noch enger
zu knüpfen und so entstanden die so
genannten staatsunternehmen die putin
gesetzlich mit vorzugsbehandlung und
privilegien aller art schützt es wird
geschätzt dass diese konzerne zwischen
55 prozent der russischen wirtschaft
kontrollieren somit handelt es sich um
eine variante des staatskapitalismus die
putin eine noch nie da gewesene
kontrolle über die wichtigsten
produktionssektoren des landes und auch
über deren eigentümer gegeben hat
[Musik]
anders als in der jetzt in ihrer
beschränkten sich die russischen
oligarchen in der praxis also nicht mehr
darauf eigentümer großer industrie
konglomerat zu sein sondern sind vor
allem für die verwaltung dieser konzern
im auftrag des krieges verantwortlich
auf diese weise gelangen die bestechungs
und schutzgelder dieser großen
unternehmen alle großen schaltstellen im
land
dies ist die große transformation die
wladimir putin durchgeführt hat und die
ihm eine nie dagewesene macht verliehen
hat es erklärt auch warum sich die
meisten oligarchischen trotz der
internationalen sanktionen unter denen
russland nach dem einmarsch in die
ukraine leidet kommt zu wort gemeldet
haben schließlich hängen sie mehr von
putin ab als dieser von ihnen natürlich
führt dieses system zu einem sehr
niedrigen niveau an produktivität
innovation und wettbewerbsfähigkeit aber
es garantiert eine enorme stabilität für
alle beteiligten mit einer klitzekleinen
ausnahme der großen mehrheit des
russischen volkes so mine liegen
zuschauer nachdem wir uns so tapfer
durch die abstrakte theorie gebissen
haben können wir endlich konkret werden
und ross und reiter benennen wer genau
sind denn die wichtigsten oligarchischen
russland ist also einmal aufgepasst
[Musik]
die freunde des krimis
derzeit gibt es in russland drei arten
von oligarchen erstens wären da die
freunde putins also diejenigen die auf
persönlicher ebene mit den präsidenten
verbunden sind sozusagen sein innerer
kreis wir sprechen hier zum beispiel von
ehemaligen freundin aus sankt petersburg
wo der russische präsident aufgewachsen
ist oder von ehemaligen kollegen des kgb
dann gibt es da noch die leiter der
sicherheits dienste des fsb der polizei
und des militärs welche eis silowiki
bekannt sind und schließlich haben wir
die außenseiter bei der letzten gruppe
handelt es sich um menschen die putin
buchstäblich alles zu verdanken haben
menschen die es geschafft haben ihren
reichtum in unvorstellbare maße zu
vermehren seit putin an der macht es sie
sind die häufigsten unter den gläubigen
absolute putin fanatiker
[Musik]
nehmen wir zum beispiel den fall von
juri kowaltschuk der als putins
persönliche banker bekannt ist und ein
vermögen von 17 milliarden dollar
angehäuft hat er ist derzeit der
hauptaktionär der russia bank einer der
größten banken des landes aber wenn das
nach viel geld klingt dann schau dir
leonid michelson einen weiteren
persönlichen freund des russischen
präsidenten michael so und verfügen über
ein geschätztes vermögen von 18,1
milliarden dollar unsere laut forbes auf
platz 66 der reichsten menschen der welt
geführt michaelson ist gründer und
direktor des erdgas unternehmens novatec
das derzeit vom westen gerade wegen
seiner verbindung zum kreml sanktioniert
wird
ein weiterer persönlicher freund des
präsidenten gennadi timtschenko hat es
geschafft über seine
investmentgesellschaft wolga group über
die er in verschiedenen unternehmen
investiert die von anderen oligarchen
kontrolliert werden das vermögen von
sage und schreibe 15 7 milliarden dollar
anzuhäufen
[Musik]
im lager der silowiki die gagen die aus
dem staatlichen sicherheitsdiensten
kommen haben wir das beispiel von horst
eckel der jetzt präsident des russischen
ölkonzerns rosneft ist aber in den
achtziger jahren ein sowjetischer spion
in mosambik war obwohl seine tätigkeit
offiziell nur als übersetzer angegeben
wurde putin war selbst viele jahre lang
beim kgb als kind der sowjetunion hat er
sich ganz bewusst für eine sichere
karriere in jenem teil des systems
entschieden der wohl am stärksten von
allen für gesetz und charakterlosigkeit
für hinterhältigkeit und niedertracht
sowie flüge und unterdrückung stand hier
ist er groß geworden hat alles für sein
späteres leben und macht streben wir
lernt putin hat daher früh erkannt dass
die vollständige kontrolle über die
geheimdienste und die absolute loyalität
ihrer chefs ein wichtiger schritt zur
konsolidierung seiner macht ist
allerdings ist er bei der wahl seiner
mittel zur erlangung dieser kontrolle in
seine eigene falle getappt er hasst die
geheimdienstler mit geld zugeschüttet um
sie vor sich abhängig zu machen
ironischerweise hat putin damit aber
solche leute an die oberfläche gespült
die aus demselben holz geschnitzt wie er
selbst geldgierig kleptomanin individuen
aber wer gierig ist will nun mal immer
mehr und mehr und genau dies führte zu
putins größten fehler die verschlagene
ratte bis sich in ihren eigenen schwanz
denn es sieht ganz danach aus dass den
geheimdienstlern die zuwendungen ihres
meisters nicht genug waren weswegen sie
noch kräftig aus ihren budgets clown
mussten davon betroffen waren wohl auch
jene mittel man munkelt über 100
millionen dollar mit denen in der
ukraine ein netzwerk von infiltratoren
und verräter aufgebaut werden sollte
welche bei der invasion dafür sorgen
würden dass die ukrainischen
sicherheitskräfte schnell aufgeben oder
gar überlaufenden den fsb chefs war
diese ganze arbeit aber wohl zu mühselig
sie steckten sich die kohle lieber
selbst in die taschen schrieben ein paar
fake berichte inklusive vetter
spesenabrechnungen und meldeten an putin
mission accomplished ja und der rest ist
geschichte es sieht ganz danach aus dass
das ergebnis dieses krieges schon vor
seinem ausbruch quasi auf diese internen
geheimdienst ebene entschieden war
und schließlich gibt es in der gruppe
der außenseite einer reihe von männern
die es geschafft haben sich vor coop den
säuberungen der jelzin oligarchie zu
retten einer von ihnen ist wladimir
potanin der von dlcs kredite für
aktienprogramm profitierte und ein
vermögen von heute 16,5 milliarden
dollar angehäuft hat
botanik bis 30 prozent von norilsk
nickel einem großen bergbauunternehmen
sowie anteile als versicherungen medien
erdöl oder einer langen liste anderer
unternehmen wie du siehst wird im
russland von heute das vermögen nicht
durch unternehmerischen einfallsreichtum
gemacht sondern vor allem durch den
kontakt zum kreml bonn schon in dich in
acht den wir reden hier nicht über
kleingeld wie wir bereits erwähnt haben
verfügen die großen russischen
milliardären man vermögen zwischen 400
und 800 milliarden dollar das problem
ist dass dieses modell es ermöglicht
einfach gestrickte unternehmen zu
betreiben die nur quantitativ aufgebläht
sind aber keine allzu komplexe
unternehmensprozesse mit hohem mehrwert
zustande bringen und genau das ist eines
der größten probleme russlands das land
ist nicht in der lage mehr als ein
reiner exporteur von rohstoffen zu sein
die eben beschriebene art der korruption
erstickt jede mögliche entwicklung
chance des landes im keim das ist der
grund warum russland eines der und
leisten und am wenigsten wohlhabenden
länder der welt ist und natürlich
besteht für die großen russischen
oligarchen der anreiz den kreml
unermüdlich zu unterstützen darin ihr
süßes leben zu genießen und botschafter
moskaus an den reichsten orten der welt
zu werden natürlich werden sie durch die
sanktionen im moment hart getroffen die
großen organischen zu sanktionieren ist
gleichbedeutend damit den russischen
staat zu treffen weshalb sie von den
alliierten ja auch so stark ins visier
genommen wurden diese hoffnung darauf
dass der druck ausreicht in moskau ein
gewisses stühlerücken in gang zu setzen
schließlich ist davon auszugehen dass
niemand seinen status verlieren möchte
und all das erklärt warum viele länder
die oligarchen noch härter sanktionieren
als andere russische institutionen
[Musik]
deswegen so zahlreiche russische
oligarchen derzeit zuflucht in ländern
wie dubai denn wenn es darauf ankommt
sie sich vielleicht diejenigen die bucht
ihn am wenigsten vertrauen können wir
werden ihnen auf jeden fall auf den
fersen bleiben dies dadurch stimmt nicht
das erste und auch nicht das letzte
video über sie in einem früheren video
haben wir euch ja bereits über den
wichtigen politischen jewgeni britschen
erzählt der die berüchtigte warner
gruppe unterhält jene von gefährlichen
neonazi demetrio gen angeführte privates
helfertruppe tc
[Musik]
ich werde euch dieses video verlinken
und mich dann auf die arbeit an einem
weiteren organischen video stürzen in
dem es um london grad geht gemeint ist
natürlich die britische hauptstadt
landen welche wegen ihrer hohen
konzentration an russischen oligarchen
als deren bisherige hauptstadt außerhalb
russlands geld nun scheint sie jedoch
mehr oder weniger hart gegen ihre gäste
vorzugeben vergesst also bitte nicht das
abo mit glöckchen um keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen aber jetzt seid
ihr erst mal an der reihe uns eure
meinung zu geigen glaubt ihr dass die
sanktionen die oligarchischen dazu
bringen werden putin zu verraten was
hältst du von diesen klicken
merkantilismus der in russland herrscht
sollten westliche regierungen die
russischen oligarchen unnachgiebig
verfolgen ich meine nicht nur wegen der
ukraine sondern auch zum wohle des
russischen volkes wie immer sind wir auf
eure kommentare schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas
gelernt habt was ja gibt uns mit einem
live chat mit freunden und vergesst
nicht das abo mit glücklichem keines
unserer videos mit zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den paypal
link dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]